we've lived in the last 50 60 years
through most of my life in a world
economic system that you helped design
and build you're one of the architects
and builders of a global system that has
produced relative peace and prosperity
for 65 years it seems to be coming apart
right now it seems to being torn apart
you've talked about three big forces
demography technology governance as
shaping the future what's the future for
the international system that is being
pressed by giant forces like that and
the politics of Washington today
well the politics of Washington is
increasingly irrelevant I think we're
seeing the creation of what I call a new
federalism where we say there's a
problem here and we're people in San
Francisco let's talk about them and
solve them ourselves and for instance I
think one of the big things about the
future people don't realize how powerful
it is is the change in demographics
that's going on all of the major
countries have falling fertility and
rising longevity so they're being turned
upside down used to be the case where
there was a lot of young people and a
few older people and that affected your
retirement systems and everything now
it's very different there are fewer
young people a lot more older people so
you got to adjust to that in Russia
China Germany Japan working age
populations are declining and certainly
Oregon continues there are three
countries where the fertility and
longevity are true but nevertheless
we're not declining in our working age
population those three countries are the
United States Canada and Australia what
are these three countries have in common
we're all immigrant countries